like if you really love somebody then
you would want what is best for them in
all
places you and i our vows were to
support each other to realize our
greatest dreams
that was what we said and
i think we've done that
there's something about that that
the differences that live
and breathe between us that create
something powerful about our union we
had a joke the other day because
it was like a saturday morning and i was
getting ready to go out on my bike
and i'm in my cycling kit my helmet and
sunglasses and the whole thing and you
came down
from a meditation session and you had
like sandalwood on your forehead
like ash on my forehead and i was like
oh wow we're both in our costumes
different costumes yeah yeah and those
costumes on some level
are a manifestation of of
some truth within each of us but they're
still costumes sure
definitely right definitely and listen
it's again it's about you
being you it's about you embodying who
you are and so
you know your truth may be to really
just be in that
and that's natural for you that's the
way it is for you
um and you can marvel at me but you
don't have to judge me
and you don't have to want to be like
anybody else except you
right i mean you do the same to me
you're like wow look at you you're in
that
look at look at that get up you got on
or whatever you know it's like you're
never going to get in a cycling kit no
don't ride with me exactly so no and i
don't expect you to and i don't judge
you for not wanting to do that yeah
exactly
but here we are 21 years later
21 years into our relationship it's
crazy which makes us just by sheer
time makes us relationship experts
that's right
you know and our and our relationship
our marriage is
is surviving the pandemic so for people
and maybe this is like a final thing a
thread that we can pull on
for people that that are i mean i can
imagine
if you're in a relationship and you're
stuck in a living
space with somebody and it's not going
well how painful
that must be and i think that's a very
common experience right now
what's the answer so the question no
well it's more like what's the quite
like
what is let's just talk about
tools for
navigating tricky relationships
like for us so much of it is about
communication
i mean we're well suited to each other
we've been we were together forever
before the pandemic so it's not like oh
we just met and now we're
in an apartment but a lot of people are
in that situation well i mean
i think again it's like this is a this
is a moment
it's an opportunity it's a it's a great
shift everybody's going through
huge changes our cultures our systems
our money
our art the way art is sold uh traveling
we had a big conversation about nfts
with mathis at dinner the other night
like this is gonna
you know sh as an art student like pay
attention to this because this is gonna
change the nature of art and how it's
valued
maybe you should explain that to the
listeners do you think they all know we
now it's too you don't have time if you
don't know what that means then we're
just not going to explain it to you
yeah so um so the thing is is um
it's a time of transformation this is
this is what it is and so
i think many of you that are listening
to this you you know this within
yourselves you know
if you're at a crossroads or if there's
a choice that's come up for your review
and i still maintain you know what i
what i've always represented and what
has been the foundation of our
relationship and that is
you're here to live your life like
you're here to live what you
what is inside of you the the treasures
are inside your own heart
and so it just leads me back to the
beginning is you got to look at whatever
you're hiding from
what are you hiding from you can't hide
from yourself
at some point you're going to have to
experience
interact with reconcile and no matter
how scary it is
communication first of all with yourself
is the first step
and then communication with those around
you and hopefully
it's not always easy for people because
not everybody are great communicators
but
if you can communicate what it is you're
feeling
and you know you have the possibility to
rewrite
the way relationships are re-write
sexuality
rewrite what it means to be married i
mean for goodness
sakes no one's straight anymore one of
my kids said to me the other day he's
like
mom no one's straight um you know so
it's like we have all this sexual
identity everybody's pan
fluid bi whatever you know transgender
what
all this stuff's coming up and so it's
like
uh we need to just love ourselves and
understand that it's gonna be okay
and that everything must change
everything
has to go through a transformation and
so because i don't like suffering
i want you to do it in the most gentle
way possible
i don't like humans to suffer i also
think
we should refrain from an old idea of a
patterning that means
x when someone breaks up you know that
we can do this people make fun of it you
know oh i'm consciously uncomfortably
like oh that's so funny but it's
actually like if you really love
somebody
and you you really love them then you
would want what is best for them in all
in all places in all stages of their
life
and you know you and i our vows were to
support each other to realize our
greatest dreams
that was what we said and
i think we've done that i think we've
you know we've held up to that
and every relationship is changing and
moving and
you know it's not about where you were
or the old story
it's about who are we today and what are
we doing going forward and what is
left to be uncovered inside of me what
is left to be uncovered inside of you
and how can we support that you know so
um i think you know it's all about you
and you
it's this deep communion with your own
self
and when you learn to advocate for
yourself then you will make choices that
are considering yourself first
which is rather contrary to the way
we've been raised
you know we we think it's spiritual to
martyr yourself
but no the martyr doesn't help anybody
in the end
and you know so wouldn't it be better
to just honor yourself and you'll find
out that if you
start treating yourself with that kind
of respect
and love and celebration that will be
mirrored back to you
right you will then attract a
like-minded
partner who's vibrating on that level or
you'll just get energy
that's supporting you yeah i mean the
instinct is
i feel uncomfortable with who i
am i'm gonna reach out and try to find
somebody else and bring them
into my world to solve my pain or
my poor self-esteem or whatever it is
that i'm contending with
and that's the upside down
way of going about it like be the person
become the person commit yourself to
becoming the person
that you that the person you aspire to
be with would want to be with
right and then figure out and then that
person will
if you do that that person will find
their way
into your life without having to go on a
dating app
and should you find yourself in that
precious situation it then becomes about
honoring yourself and honoring the best
of what that other person has to offer
which is very easy to say and very
difficult to do
very complicated right yeah we have a
friend who you told the story at dinner
the other night
about um being told to not be on a
dating app anymore
oh right right right i won't say who it
is but
well i don't even know i mean dating
apps like we are totally the
unexpected i got a question one of us
the other day i have no idea but i can't
give any advice about dating no we can't
even speak to that we're too old
we're like you know we're that that
we're that generation we didn't do that
yeah i don't know i mean um again it
everything
in in my estimation my best
my best offering is it's all about
building an absolutely
devotional relationship with yourself
because there's nothing more beautiful
than a being that knows itself
and there's no one else that is going to
find that connection except you
no one's going to do that work for you
so
if you're compromising or if you've
bonded with somebody over
pain and pain is the subject of your
life
um you have the ability to transmute
that
to learn from it to bless it to thank it
and to
if you've learned enough from it if you
haven't learned enough from it then stay
there
i mean there's valuable lessons to be
learned in all life experiences
and it's not just about one tone
you know but the main thing is are you
getting the lesson
are you transforming you know did you
take away something from it
and then we have to make peace with our
[Music]
traumas
[Music]
you